our ongoing series a more perfect union
aims to show that what unites us as
Americans is far greater than what
divides us today we're looking at a
partnership between a university and a
retirement home that's giving residents
the best of both worlds
we traveled to Des Moines Iowa to visit
Gabby clutter a 22 year old student with
a unique college experience gabby
clutter is like any other senior vocal
performance major at Drake University in
Des Moines Iowa except for when she
leaves campus and heads home when you
got into college did you ever think
you'd be living in a retirement
community health I do not something that
I thought was even possible yes Gabby
clutters senior year housing is actually
a senior living community are you going
to zip line no Deerfield about 15
minutes from Drake it was an idea that
we had as part of having a healthy
living community executive director
James Robinson said Deerfield launched
their artist-in-residence program two
years ago because student from Drake is
selected given a free apartment and
meals then integrate it into the senior
community where'd the idea come from to
have somebody who's in college living at
a retirement community well we're not
the pioneer for doing this this has been
done at other communities in the United
States and in other countries but it was
something that we felt passionate about
doing here at Deerfield so what's it
been like having Gabi here it's been
just amazing 89 year old Glennis nun was
one of the first residents to welcome
Gabi to her new homes what was it about
Gabi that made her the right person to
be here her willingness to come to give
up college life can come live at an at a
retirement community she you know we
give her a room and board right as she
said a washer and dryer at a parking
place inside what more could you ask me
especially in Iowa winters that is big
big seems like you have this amazing
opportunity to get a bunch of
grandparents you have in your life yes
yes yeah I have a couple that I recently
started dating someone and I told them
about it and they're like well he needs
to come here for dinner but grandma's
need to approve and so it's just it's
really nice I understand it was a
requirement that she bring her boyfriend
I don't know what we would have said if
we didn't I'm sure you would have told
her yeah probably
I will be seeing is called a beautiful
song yo
besides socializing with residents the
only cost for Gabby's room and board a
couple of recitals a month an activity
she says has given her more confidence
as a performer but both Gabby and the
residents say the greatest benefit of
the program is the chance to learn from
another generation it's such a cool
experience not only for the residents
but for the people at Drake tooks I
always have my friends come and they see
how special it is and how important it
is to connect to people outside of their
little bubble what it's been so nice
about having some younger people here
the interaction and just seeing the the
youth you know we hear so many awful
things about young people and now we see
the best things like horrible how
interested they aren't us and that was a
surprise to me so often young people
stereotype anyone that maybe over 50 or
40 but you get up into people who are 80
and older mid seventies I think they
think that we're all in wheelchairs and
not interested in anything and they find
out a whole different aspect and why is
that important not to be afraid of Aging
and I
maybe respect for older people I think
that's very important do you think
you've gotten more from this program or
put in more to this program I think it's
pretty equal gabby is the second student
to be part of Deerfield's
artist-in-residence program
Glennis said perhaps next they'll have a
male resident or someone who plays an
instrument as well it's really
fascinating Glennis estate in touch with
the first resident and they all told me
it's this friend that they now have in
their lives friend like family that
they've lived with I just loved this
story Dana it's such a beautiful one and
I know that you worked on this with Dana
Brewington just the idea what Glennis
says getting insights from a young
person and they can also see what we're
all about yeah you know she has
grandchildren but she said it's
different when she's with her
grandchildren and the conversations they
have they'll just go hang out and have
fun it really is it's mutually
beneficial it teaches like she said
people not to be afraid of aging and I
know she has a boyfriend but I'm sure
there would be plenty of object such a
beautiful story thank you thank you